So the right answer is (n log n). Why is that?
So here's the n = 4 hypercubed square
and recall that the bit patterns have 2 bits in them,
and, in general, the number of bits in the label
of a node and then hypercubed with n edges is log n--
log base 2 of n, specifically.
So that means the degree of each node,
in this particular graph--it's 2--but, in general, the degree is log n.
So that means each of the nodes in the graph
has log n edges coming out of it,
so we can think of n times the log of n as the number of edges,
but we have to be careful, because we double counted again.
This node is connected to this one,
but this one is also connected back to this one by the same bit pattern.
Exact answer is 1/2 n log n, but that's okay.
In Bit Theta land, we can ignore the 1/2,
and we have Bit Theta and then log n.